- Everyone, I'm Caitlin.
I'm going to be doing a little bit
of like a coding tutorial
today based in R and shiny
for those that haven't
worked with R or shiny,
we have linked on the page
some other videos kind of
introing R and shiny separately.
So you do need a little bit of background
for those those two languages and packages
to kind of get a-- feel
comfortable with this video,
also linked a bunch of really
fabulous free R resources.
If you want to really dive
into R not just for data viz
but for data science and
programming in general.
I really wanted to focus
on kind of like a hands-on
sort of example of how you can work
with actual COVID-19 data,
that's out there and it's public.
There's a lot of it out there.
Not all of them are created
equal unfortunately,
some of them are so messy.
It's hard to even explain how messy it is.
We're going to start with a
kind of more friendly example
from the New York City Health Department,
so since I'm in New York City,
Rockefeller's in New York city,
this is a more personal kind
of like look at COVID-19.
We're gonna start on GitHub actually
with the source of the
data I'll be using today.
For those that haven't
worked with GitHub before
it's a really phenomenal kind of place
for the broader data community.
So the format of this is essentially
what are called repositories
or repos are shared
and stored on here.
So this is sort of the username
for the Health Department
and so actually don't know
they probably have other data here.
We can take a take a quick peek.
Oh, it turns out it's just COVID data.
Yeah. So a fun thing about COVID
for a lot of Health Departments
is the kind of urgent need
to share data with the public
was really fast and a
lot of Health Departments
had no capacity to do this in any way,
let alone just like handle
and collect the data.
New York City in general
for various departments
has pretty good like open data resources,
totally recommend checking
out those data sets
because there's a lot of really fun stuff
you can learn about the city that way.
Like COVID kind of hit everyone very fast
and the need for information
and the need to talk
about that information
and then subsequently visualize
and analyze that information
was really fast and New
York City had the capacity
to ramp up, but a lot of places didn't,
and it took them a while to get to a place
where they could share data,
so as a fun scavenger
hunt on your own time
you can probably try to look at data
from other state's counties
to get a sense of the
variability of how this looks,
this is the repository we're
going to work with today.
There's a lot in here.
We're not mapping every
single thing on here.
The game plan will be to
create a map of the city
and broken down by a
sort of form of zip code
which we'll talk about in a bit,
on top of that map obviously
we care about COVID data
and the spread of COVID-19.
So we'll be looking at
a few different metrics
the kind of most basic
one being case rate.
So cases appearing per a
certain number of people
in the population.
Take a minute to look at the data itself
and what it is, I talked
a lot in the last video
about how you really have to
be familiar with your data
before you even begin to
think about visualizing it.
The NYC Health Department,
has their own set of
visualizations actually
on their data webpage.
We're going to make
something similar to that,
but we'll be focusing mostly
on just a handful of metrics.
Whereas I think they're
showing a bit more.
Already you can see,
and this is mirrored
on the GitHub as well,
how they're defining cases.
What is a confirmed case?
People with a positive molecular test,
probable cases people with
a positive antigen test.
So the right, there are different ways
in which we're assessing someone
having or not having COVID.
You guys are probably familiar
with many different types
of tests that are available,
ones that are detecting
the presence of an antigen
ones that are based on PCR.
There are many different ways
in which you can actually detect COVID-19.
And because of that, there are
many ways to actually define
someone having a case or not.
So we're going to make a
kind of version of this.
So this is a static map what's
known as a Chloropeth map.
So that just means that
regions are sort of colored
by a data point.
In this case, it's a seven
day percent positive.
So what does that mean?
Percent of people that had
a test who tested positive
that's actually quite
strict definition, right?
This is not like the percent
of the full population
that tested positive.
This is the percent of the people
that actually had tests
that tested positive.
And they have this really important,
note here that all data are incomplete
because we're not testing
every single person.
And the other feature
here, this is a seven day.
So what does that mean?
Seven day means that,
these numbers are being
aggregated on a weekly basis.
Individual days can really
mess up data collection.
And so to kind of correct for that noise
or kind of attribute
too much interpretation
or weight to one given day,
you average across seven days
to calculate a percent positivity rate,
you can imagine if this was
a daily percent positive
let's say, I don't know,
somewhere down here in
the lower East side,
one of this zip codes
maybe three days of data were input
or collected for some reason on one day
instead of, you know split
across those three days.
If someone were looking on
one day from the day before,
and like coming back to this map
and seeing all of a sudden
this becomes a much, much darker color.
They can interpret thinking like,
oh my God something happened
on this day to cause you know,
some huge burst in percent positivity
which wouldn't be the truth, right?
That's like a slower division of time.
So kind of drop in all those new cases.
So this is why we have the weekly averages
or aggregations I should
say of percent positive.
It's more stable and reflects
kind of change happening
in real time.
Some people actually
even extend this further
to further reduce the
kind of potential noise.
So like 14 day, for example
we just had the holidays in December.
And so that was actually
like a huge problem
with reporting in a lot of states counties
the weekly averages were
actually susceptible to that,
because there was this kind
of longish period of time
for some people need more
than a week of vacation
and people weren't getting tested.
There were backlogs from
on the reporting end.
There were these kind of
artificial drops in numbers,
which you know people
had to sort of clarify
for their audiences through our
publishing data around this.
Hopefully they did, some
of them I'm sure did not.
This is kind of a map sort
of what we're going to do
but we're actually going to do this,
over the course of several months.
So starting in August
this seven day numbers
this calculation,
didn't start happening
actually in New York City
until early August.
Jumping back over to the GitHub repo.
If you look at any GitHub repository
you often will encounter
a readme mark down page
that's what M D stands for.
This is pretty awesome in
terms of how well explained
the data is, it even goes
into detail about like
how to download the data,
like how to make requests
if you have questions,
you can submit an issue on GitHub
also updates to the
way in which maybe data
is being described
or the new types of metrics
that are being included
at different points.
'Cause these things happen.
For example,
they change from PCR test
to molecular test, right?
This is a technical distinction,
but they get into this stuff.
There are so many different kind of facets
to talking about COVID and
they really do a nice job here
of explaining the data.
On your own time you
can definitely explore
the different types of data here
but we're going to focus on trends
since we're going to look over
the course of several months.
And so in this folder,
we have lots of CSVs.
So that's, comma-separated.
The department recommends
against interpreting daily changes
as one day's worth of data,
due to the difference between date
of event and date of report.
So that's really key too.
It's something I didn't actually
mention of people associating
an event being recorded on a given day
as it actually happening on that day,
but think about in real life,
if you've tested for COVID
or have had COVID
and that testing event
could also be lagged
between when it's actually
reported to the system.
There's not this kind of
like instantaneous thing
where you get a positive
test in some systems,
somewhere on a server it gets updated
to indicate your positive COVID case.
So that's an inherent flaw
with what these types
of reporting weekly data
so we're going to be focusing on.
And so there's a lot of data in here,
antibody testing, case rate,
which is one of the ones
we're going to look at,
again, the cases by day
which has all of these different metrics.
And these kind of prefixes here
are actually sorted by borough.
So people wanted to
compare for New York City,
you know like the Bronx
versus Manhattan versus Queens
versus Staten Island.
These were important
especially kind of getting
broader area aggregations
of hotspots and things like that.
Deaths by day. Hospitalizations by day.
Percent positive again, is
when we're going to use.
And then we're also
going to take test rate.
If you notice the three data
points that I'm mentioning
are ones that are followed by MODZCTA.
So ZCTA is a specific
type of geography, right?
So we can talk about across the city.
We can talk about borough
or should I mentioned before
so it's like kind of sub
regions within the city
but then we can talk about zip codes.
MODZCTA actually is not exactly zip codes
which I'm going to talk about in a bit
but it's a way to map
what are regions defined
by different zip codes.
So it's much smaller region
to get a sense of COVID spread
in those smaller regions.
So much like this map, right?
These are this MODZCTA
regions I was talking about.
This is much better than
just kind of comparing
the full borough.
Why?
All for those that know their
boroughs in New York City,
you can look within these big boroughs
and you can see that there are actually
lot of variability across
that even adjacent zip codes.
So that is actually really
important to inform a public
that is concerned about travel
or concerned about quarantines
and transmission of the virus
and all of this stuff, right?
So people wanting to be informed
about severity of the disease.
And this is also helpful for
people on the government side
who are trying to figure out,
you know where to prioritize resources,
if COVID is more severely spreading
in one region versus another.
This also affects hospitals too, right?
Hospitals being either
distributed evenly across the city
or not which is definitely not the case
but you know, if a hospital is here
it's gonna need more resources probably
than a hospital here.
So that is why we're looking
at these sort of smaller regions.
Again, I'm sort of, you know,
filtering and making decisions
about the visit we're going to make today
since this is more of a tutorial
but there's a lot of data here.
And so you don't have to
do exactly what I'm doing.
And this is meant to just sort of teach
how to make a specific
type of visualization.
It's going to be interactive as well too.
So this one, when you hover over
you get some information
about each zip code
whatever you do, if you're
working with this data
if you're working with a different dataset
make sure you're
understanding what the data is.
This is super detailed.
We're doing the seven day
aggregations as well too.
So people with the molecular tests
are aggragated by four
weeks from each Sunday
to the following Saturday.
And that's how they're classed and log.
So again this is seven day aggregations.
We want to download this data, to do so,
there are actually a couple
different ways you can do this.
If you have experienced
with the command line
you can actually just
kind of interface directly
with GitHub, using Git
commands G-I-T, Git commands
to pull this repository.
That way you can download it manually.
So literally clicking here code
you can download the zip file.
Additionally, clone the repo as well too,
if you're working within GitHub yourself
and have your own GitHub repo, right?
You can, what's called fork
the data over creating
essentially like a copy of it
and then branching it off into
your own space to work with,
the way we're going to do it today.
I'll show two different
ways we're using R,
you can actually copy
the link address here
where it says download zip.
So it's right clicking your command,
clicking on what you're
doing, copy link address.
The other thing you can do
with RStudio is you can use this address.
Which is ending in a dot
git when you load RStudio.
So now that we're in R,
if you don't know some of the terminology
I'm using about R or shiny
definitely check out
those other intro videos.
I've done introducing the language
and like how to work
with some basic stuff.
I'm starting off with a
pretty much clean workspace.
One thing you can do if
you like to use R projects
is you can start a session
in a GitHub repo too,
so for example, if you go here
I'm not actually going to do
this but when you do a project,
you can make a, its own
directory and all this stuff
set up a new working directory.
But if you want it to
start with a git repo
you go to version control,
which is the main benefit
for using GitHub is you can
track versions over time.
If you click git repo URL.
So that was that git
addressed I was showing you
on the NYC Health GitHub page.
You drop in here, give it a name
and you can put it wherever
you want on your computer.
So that's an option too.
The way I'm doing it here
is a little bit more sort
of direct within the script.
So I'm calling this script
NYC COVID prep data.R,
and you'll see why in a second.
This is how I'm downloading the file.
So, first of course, I'm
setting my working directory.
So wherever you want to
work on this project,
make a clean directory for
it to clean folder for it
and set your RStudio initialized
to go to that working directory.
So once you do that, you download the file
and that URL for the actual
zip, download those here
and then you set a desk file.
And so this is going to
be the name of that file.
And this is the name of the
repo entirely data master.
That's zip.
And that's going to be
the folder that pops up
I could run this super quickly
and it downloaded that zip.
And then we can actually just
unzip it now that it's there.
So I already moved to
where my directory is.
I've already done it before,
so you are going to see
this already but if you,
for example, the data
is updated all the time.
So if you wanted to do it over again,
you'll read download this
zip, which is what I just did
and then unzip it in the same location
and it all unzip there.
And so it did that.
And so let's just take a look
to make sure it's all there.
Yes, it is, we have R folders.
So, right?
The trends folder is going
to be where we're gonna grab
that percent positive by
MODZCTA test rate as well,
again by MODZCTA and
then case rate as well
two or the three we're going
to grab from this folder.
So on top of any R markdown or
R scripts whatever it is,
we want to initialize some libraries.
Tidyverse is how I work
with data, data wrangling
and general recommended for everything
and includes ggplot, it
includes deep outlier,
all that good stuff.
Vroom is a much newer package.
It allows to really fast
reading and importing of data
I should say, also specifically
CSVs for the most part
it can recognize delimiters
and it can import stuff
pretty quickly on that front.
So that's awesome.
SF and tigris are packages
to working with spatial geographic data.
So that's important.
I'm kind of listing here why
we're importing all this stuff.
So quickly start up all of these guys.
So now these guys are
all set up and so vroom
like I said before, this
is a way to read in data.
I like vroom for CSV files that
are pretty straight forward.
So usually I look at the delimiter, right?
And so what I'm doing here, right?
Is I'm reading in these data frames.
And so as you can see here,
I vroomed in this CSVs.
It recognizes it's a comma
separated file, right?
So a comma
and it's linking in all
of these different values,
the columns.
And so these are three
separate data frames
that I've just generated right now.
Let's take a look at a case rate first
just to see what this data looks like
always the first thing you want to do.
And there are a lot of columns here.
So this is the raw data from the city.
So we have one column.
So remember,
I mentioned that this type of
second seven day aggregation
didn't really start until
August of this year, right?
A lot has changed since August.
So it's fun to look at, fun or depressing
fun to look at the trends in time
just even over these past few months.
So right, We have week ending.
And so that means the cases reported
in these subsequent columns
are reported from that Sunday
before through that end
date that's listed here.
So that's why it's week ending.
And so we have data all the
way up to fresh start in 2021.
So that's our kind of
like last week to compare
and not going across,
so these are pretty
nicely labeled columns.
We have case rate over the city.
And so why is it a rate and
why is it not just a raw number
of cases that data does exist in the repo.
If you want to take a look
at the raw numbers of cases,
but this rate as the
GitHub readme mentioned
is calculated as the number
of cases per 100,000 people.
So if you remember from my last video
why is this happening?
We want to get a rate that
is including the information
about population or some sort
of per capita measurement
because we really need
to normalize for numbers.
There are many different numbers of people
in different parts of the city.
The population is
concentrated differently.
And so you can't compare
any region to another
unless you do some sort of
normalization for the population.
So this is why we're
looking at case rates here
as opposed to just number of cases.
So we have case rates across the city
New York City does not have
the same kind of COVID spread
because it's super regional.
And so we have borough breakdowns
and then we get into the zip codes.
So 10001 all the way 10280
and this is cool, right?
This is a lot of data in here.
And the data looks clean.
It looks, there's not a
lot of like weird errors
with the formatting of the data.
A good thing to always check
when you get a new data set too
is check the class of the
different, you know, variables.
Yeah. We have doubles here, which is good.
These are just numeric data.
The date, however, is actually
a character which is fine.
There are a couple of things we gonna do,
We'll see in the code to change that.
Yeah double checking what
your data structure is,
before you even do anything with analysis.
The other point I wanted to make is,
remember this this data
file was by MODZCTA.
So let's talk about what MODZCTA is,
because it's a little confusing
again, if we need you have
a question about the data
cutting into the actual
readme for the GitHub repose
is a really good place to start.
The data here is accompanied
by this lovely explanation.
So MODZCTA stands for Modified
Zip Code Tabulation Area
and ZCTA is just Zip Code Tabulation Area
because the zip code,
as it's explained here
isn't actually a domain.
It's not like a county or a state.
It's actually a collection of points
that make up a mail delivery route
which is not something
we typically think about.
But when we're talking
about regions and space,
and so when when we're
dealing with mapping in R,
really any software mapping for viz,
we need to actually understand
what the regions are bound by.
There are these issues as well too with,
you know, some areas
like having their own,
buildings having their own zip code,
or weird stuff like that.
Essentially what the
Health Department did,
is create modifications to these ZCTAs
that take these like tiny little zip codes
that are affiliated with like
maybe a building or something
and combine them into like a
slightly bigger region, right?
To make these estimates
for population size,
bore legitimate, because
dividing by a hundred thousand,
you know, is a good
normalization across the board,
but doing it for a place
that has a tiny population
it might not actually capture
the regional spread of a disease.
So you want to keep your
geographies like fairly comparable
in terms of size,
a little bit of aggressive
detail for mapping,
but this is the kind of thing you run into
especially when you're dealing
with geographical data.
So to deal with this they offer
this ZCTA to MODZCTA file.
Just take a quick look at that.
And you'll notice for the most part it
it's like a one-to-one mapping.
It's like, oh, why did they
even bother doing this?
It's not all zip codes, right?
This is pretty much uniform for everything
until you get down here, look at this.
So the MODZCTA is on this side.
This one MODZCTA is encapsulating
several different zip codes
because those are like
tiny, tiny little zip codes
not comparable to maybe a
more standardized zip code
the way we're going to handle this,
is we're going to we're
going to use the MODZCTAs.
But if you wanted to as well
to make a more enhanced visualization
you can create like a mapping system
within to convert over to ZCTA.
So a little added complexity,
the way we're going to do this
in our final app is to include this table
for lookups as well, too.
So if you live in a zip code
that maybe is one of these smaller ones,
you can go and check
and make sure it's mapping over yourself.
So these are the files we're
actually going to read in.
So where's this in
geography to sources exactly
the same as what's on the GitHub repo
just now it's in the comfort
of my little RStudio space.
There are a couple of different ways
in which a shape geography
data can be stored.
The one we're gonna work with today
is the shape files that
are SHP files from 2010.
So this is the last time these
kind of domains were defined.
And this is getting into,
you know, like some
infrastructure stuff in the city
and how these lines are drawn,
especially for things like--
I don't know, precincts
being redistricted and county
lines and all this stuff
but this is congressional districts,
like depending on what you end up doing
with this in the future,
you can get really, really
far into a shape file data
and all this stuff.
But for now, just very simply
we use this st_read function
to read in this shape file.
So this is what's necessary
to read in geographic data.
And this function is
part of the SF package
that I loaded initially early in that in,
simple feature collection with
170 features in two fields.
So this is how geometry data store,
this is literally like the lines
upon which we're drawing
these boundaries on a map
you can imagine,
and this is how R is
storing that data right now.
Now that we have our data,
we wanna work with it a bit
to get it into a space
where we can visualize it,
checking this out.
We have right, all the
data we could ever want
but it's not exactly in the
right format to work with.
Why is that?
So currently we want to
map by zip code or ZCTA,
I should say.
But right now that zip
code data is kind of spread
across this data of frame
in a classic data cleaning situation
or should I say data wrangling.
We're going to be shifting
the format of this data frame
into a long format.
And what does that mean instead of having,
you know, all of these
variables spread out
in this wide format,
where for every week we
have a different zip codes
going across this way.
We want to have a situation
where we have a column that is zip code
and the case rates are
aggregated kind of lengthwise
as opposed to across
the zip codes this way.
But this will be,
you know, a few columns
as opposed to 22 columns.
The first thing we're going
to do is actually remove,
we're not interested in the borough data
or the city-wide data.
So we're going to remove
these first few columns
which does that.
I'm calling it case rates now
just to give it a new variable name.
So let's take a look at what
that is after I do that.
So now we've got rid of that
stuff that was here, right?
The city-wide, the borough-wide
and now we just have zip code data.
Awesome, this is the reshaping.
So tidyverse introduced
actually very recently
this new function, a new set of functions
pivot wider and pivot longer.
It used to be gather and spread.
I think this is a little
bit more intuitive
that the new language,
but essentially what I'm doing right
is I'm moving into the long form format.
So pivoting it longer.
I'm taking all of these
columns 178 columns.
Actually, I think I said
22 before that was wrong.
170 columns, 22 rows and
we're going to put them all
actually now into one
column called MODZCTA.
The prefects for that is going to be,
that case rate blank, right?
So that's the prefix
that's encapsulating all
the zip code data I want
and that's going to be
kind of removed, right?
We don't want a list that
says case rate underscore
we're going to want to get rid of that.
So we just want the
actual zip code itself.
What will those values be called?
It could be a new column
just called case rate.
Currently, it's individual case rates
switching to this long
format, case rates long.
And just like that, we have
our weeks, we have our MODZCTA
and we have our case rates,
and this is a lot easier to work with
now that we will be
trying to visualize it.
So now that we've done that,
we're going to do the exact same thing
to the percent positive data frame
and the test rate data frames.
So just to prove to you
that these are almost identical in format.
Definitely, please
check before you do that
but we're just gonna
look at the head of this
just to show you it's identical, right?
So instead of case we
have PCTPOS percent pause,
city all this stuff here in
the front of the boroughs,
and then it gets in here.
So it's literally the same format.
And so that means that it allows us to use
almost the same code.
Definitely, check before of course
and same thing for test rate.
So I should say again,
the reason why it's rate
is that these numbers are calculated
per a hundred thousand people,
percent pause again is the
number of molecular tests
that ended up being a positive
out of the people that got those tests.
Okay. So I'm just gonna
run this next batch of code
and then we will have our
reshaped long format data frames.
And now that we have
those three data frames
we're going to merge the
three of those together.
So to do so again,
tidyverse gives us some
pretty cool tools left join
so left join and everything.
If you're imagining A on
the left and B on the right
and we want to join in
those two data frames
we're matching based on values,
all the values that exist
in that left data frame,
those are preserved.
And then the ones on the
right are matched over.
But we already know in
this case that actually
all three data frames are the same
in terms of the week ending, for example,
and the MODZCTA those are all the same.
Definitely double-check before you do this
because that's going to
affect the type of join you do
in this case, we're matching
to the kind of leftmost one
but and then of course
you can pipe this in.
So we're first matching case
rates long 2% positive long
and then upon that, we're
joining in test rates long
and this is a really easy place
to mess up your data frame,
depending on what values
you're matching to.
So once I run that, now that
I've merged them all in,
let's take a look at what this looks like
and this is exactly what I wanted.
So now we have all three in
one lovely little data frame
all merge on week_ending
MODZCTA case rate percent pause test rate,
but it's missing something,
it's missing that, I should
say MODZCTA shape file.
So that geography data
if you remember, looked a
little something like this,
yeah, feature collection,
geometries polygon all of that.
You'll see this multi polygon
thing for a given MODZCTA.
The two data frames
have something in common
and that's MODZCTA.
And so to do so while
preserving this geometry data
we can't just use a
standard tidyverse join.
You have to actually use
something called a geo join.
Which is a cool function
from the tigris package.
And so running this, now we've
joined the two data frames.
Now we have a geometry file,
but it includes our week
ending our case rate
or percent pause and our test rate.
And this is the data frame
that we really wanted.
We're going to make one more
change for before saving it.
But this is looking really great.
Again, here, I added a note in the code
this code we're going to
put up on the website.
We're using MODZCTA here
not technically zip codes,
even though oftentimes the
two are interchangeable
the way we're going to handle it here
is leaving the lookup table
for people to double-check,
remember how I mentioned,
of course, that the class of
all MODZCTA is a character.
We're going to make that a date
just because it allows us to
kind of track things over time
if needed.
Typically, if dates are there,
you want them to be a date
unless you have some specific
reason to class it otherwise
but this is easy to do
with the as date function.
And then finally, I'm going
to save this as a RDS format.
This is the full final data frame.
And so now this is R final data frame,
but stored in RDS format.
We want to, before we build our app
another kind of like check
to see kind of like what's
happening within this data.
Like what is going to be
the story of the data?
So to do so just focusing
on case rate first
it's a good idea to check the distribution
of anything you have.
That's kind of like numeric.
So for case rates, for example
all I'm doing here is I'm
just plotting case rate
as a numeric of course,
and just a simple histogram
to look at the range range of data.
So you can see that the
kind of range of case rates
extending out to here it's
actually imperceptibly small,
but the fact that this you
know, Y or X axis was moving out
to 1500 you kind of know the
extent of the case range.
Another way to check this
is to do min and max.
So I'm going to actually
look at max first.
So all my MODZCTA case
rate or 14 hundreds.
So that's why this is
extended all the way out here.
So just looking at this by hand
you'll see the vast majority
of the data is in this space
but it is extending out
to a lot of cases actually
so that's not great now that
we've kind of like gotten
a sense of the range here.
And again, definitely do
this for the other metrics
as well too.
So for example, like max all
and checking out some of
these other ranges as well too
and you can repeat the same thing
to get a sense of spread
across everything.
And this is important, so the reason why,
you know, getting a sense of
like the distribution of data
is a great idea just so you
know how to visualize it, right?
When we're doing sort of coloring
and making design choices,
we want to actually
represent the spread of data
to cover the range of things.
And so when we're actually thinking about,
making like a simple
version first of what will,
eventually the app will be built around.
We want to use leaflet.
So leaflet is this really
phenomenal phenomenal package
for R that uses, it's
actually called leaflet
it a JavaScript based
interactive map package.
And so checking out the
documentation for leaflet
I totally recommend there's
so much you can do with it
using the leaflet package for
R allows you to kind of access
this suite of interactive
typically you would code it
in something like Java script,
but this R package lets you
kind of get around that,
and use the suite of tools to do so.
We want to actually set these labels,
usually just HTML tool package
that's what's the HTML tools package HTML
and the sprint F function as well too.
Let's you kind of set the
formatting for the pop-up
that will be over each
one of those regions.
We hover over what we're doing here
is we're actually making so strong,
like sort of bold formatting
for the zip code itself.
Or I should say the
BODZCTA will appear on top
and then there'll be a line break
and then that'll be followed
by the case rate number itself.
So things will be shaded and aggregated,
but if you wanted to actually
see the actual case rate per,
so that's per a hundred
thousand people, right?
Case per hundred thousand
people, you could hover over
and you would get the actual
case rate for that MODZCTA.
So let's just run this to initialize that,
and I'll show you where that comes out
when we build them up.
And then we're going to
set our color palette.
So for leaflet, this is
actually like a function we set.
So we have a couple different
options to do this colorBin
colored numeric.
I'm doing bin for this, this
is really an aesthetic choice.
This is not something
that you need to like
there's only one way to do it,
but I'm using colorBin
just because I want to make it so that,
it's kind of like less
work to kind of guess
at different ranges.
And so I'm taking my range of data
so that the full range of case rate data
and bending it according
to like a set number,
I give it so colorBin,
we'll split a palette that I'm defining.
And so this is something
that's inside RColorBrewer.
If you don't know about RColorBrewer
definitely like Google
that and check that out.
There are a lot of kind
of pre available pallets
that you can choose from orange, red.
This is OrRd, is the one
I'm working with here,
as an example, to show you the range.
And so we're going to
split the all possible
kind of color values across
this palette into nine bins.
And that's the max for this palette.
This is really just an example for now.
I'm not saying this is like
the correct thing to do.
You can really, especially for database,
this is somewhere where you can spend
a lot of time tinkering and
playing with different metrics
and seeing what works best
for the data you have,
something you can do,
especially because the
data looks like this,
it's bin at such that,
you know you have a kind
of smaller range bins
at the lower end of the spectrum
and then maybe larger arrangements here.
But for this case, I'm going
to make them all equal size
just to keep it as simple as possible.
So I'm going to initialize this.
And so that's defining that pal
function and here's the code
that I've written to actually
make this interactive map.
So it's going into this variable
I'm calling map interactive
which will be the actual object.
That's the interactive map.
And I'm taking my data frame all MODZCTA
and piping that into several things.
So first this is kind of like a weird data
or I should say R cartography type thing.
It's part of the SF package,
essentially transform
the data we have into a
specific coordinate system.
So that's going to like
orient the polygons
the specific way, a lot to explain here,
but the CRS is thing of
like a coordinate system
and we're transforming
R current geography data
into this sort of format.
And then we're going to
run the leaflet function.
So taking that data and running leaflet
that's enough to sort
of like generate a map,
but we have to sort of then set
the options within that map.
And so to do so you can
add layers called tiles
or in this case provider tiles.
And this is really like the
type of map you're using.
So I'm choosing the one
that's called CartoDB.Positron
but this can be a lot of things.
So just to show you an example
this one is going to run this part.
Oops, you get this warning message,
but you can, you can
pretty much ignore that.
And so I haven't put any data on here yet
because I haven't actually
defined anything about it.
So that's why you don't
see any data on here.
And all we have is this leaflet
map using open street map
and it's the entire world.
So we're not even looking
at New City at this point
but this is sort of what that
leaflet instance generates.
And the CartoDB.Positron
is this type of map.
You can send you to change
the way the map looks.
So like different types of
projections you can play with.
If you check as always,
if you don't know what a function does,
checking the help section.
And so for a no map provider,
there are lots of types of maps out there
that you can play with.
So the actual help guide
example is stamen.watercolor.
And so let's just pop that in here
and see what it does just as
give you a sense of the range
stamen.watercolor I'm gonna run this.
And I got this crazy surreal stream
but this is cool, right?
You can imagine whole types of maps.
There are a lot of types you
can actually grab in here
different map providers,
interface with leaflet
and offer these up as
packages you can play with.
So I think that's pretty cool,
but if you're a member like
we think that this data viz
in the purpose of it, we're not trying to,
you know, showcase some awesome art,
even though it maybe in another situation
that might be what we're
trying to accomplish.
This is a very cool map,
but at the same time
we are using color in
this case to highlight
the data we care about.
So in this case, we're mapping
case rate in New York City.
And so we actually want the cases
to be the thing that's colored
and that's what the eye
is going to be drawn to.
As you load them, you can play with them
and see you can zoom in on locations.
You're getting all kinds of stuff here.
Oh boy, it's actually quite beautiful.
You can play with this and
look at the different maps
and see how they look
at different resolutions
and zoom settings.
Let me reset the map to go back to,
it looks like fairly boring
where we're going to put
some pretty stuff on there.
So again, just running that
and now we get to the data.
And so this is a lot,
there's a lot happening here.
We're gonna to walk through this slowly.
So now we're in the add polygon section.
There are lots of things you
can add to a leaflet bat.
You can add circle markers.
You can add kind of like pop up points.
We're working with polygons
because the shape file.
That's why we went through all that work
of joining in that geography
data are considered polygon
sort of like these irregular shapes.
If you wanted to add sort
of standard like little dots
or circles or some sort of like
uniform thing across there,
there's a leaflet function for that.
But in this case, we're adding polygons
because we have very specific geometries.
Those are those shape file data
showing those MODZCTA regions.
So we're using add polygons.
And within this function,
there are a lot of arguments
that you can play with.
So the very first one
is we want to make sure
we incorporate our labels
that we wrote up over here.
So this is what's going to happen
when we hover over any given polygon.
So label equals labels.
That's labels up here.
Some of the design factors
these are really not a hard and fast.
These are just things you can play with.
So the stroke of the actual polygon shape
I'm just turning that off.
Smoothing just a little bit soothing
because some of the edges
are look a little bit kind
of not super straight.
And so I just upped it up to 2.5 a bit,
just to add a little bit of soothing.
So the lines aren't super
kind of jagged aesthetically
it just looks a little bit nicer.
It doesn't change anything
about the polygon itself
opacity being one, fill opacity being 0.7,
and so these are two
different features, right?
So the opacity of the
kind of polygon outline
and then fill opacity
is like what's inside the polygon itself.
And then the most important
part here actually
is ends up being fill color
because we're trying to make
essentially a Chloropeth map.
What that is again,
is recoloring regions
based on a data metric.
So in this case, it's case rate
but it's not just case rate
because we want to apply
that color function
we defined up here.
So for all case rate values
we want to assign a
specific color on the scale
that we set up.
And that scale is going from
this orange to red colors,
sort of like a light,
it looks actually a
little more like yellowy
the light yellow color to a darker red.
And so this is the notation for that.
This is the actually function
notation I should say.
And so the fill color
and so the polygon will be filled in
according to the case rate there,
the other option again,
this is another place
where you can fiddle around with
and see how the different
features affect the shape
and look, but we're adding
in some highlight options
because we actually want
to sort of single out
the polygon you're hovering over.
So thinking for the user,
using the interactive map
if you're hovering over region,
you want there to be a
little bit of feedback
being like okay this is the
one you're hovering over.
So instead of, you know,
just to set up polygons
they're colored in a sort of static way
but they don't actually change
any sort of color when
you hover over them.
So this is just gives the
user a bit more confidence
they're hovering over the right thing
and know what they're hovering over.
So adding in a very light,
it's kind of like a gray
scale highlight option.
And this is that you bring
to front is important here
so that you actually see
that when you hover over
and then the fill is actually quite
it's almost totally filled out.
So, you know, you hover over it.
It turns like a little bit gray whitish,
and then it, you move on to another one.
It returns to its original color
already here there's a
huge range of possibilities
with what you can play with.
Again, I'm going to keep saying this
but it's important when making data viz
have a lot of kind of like tinkering
and it's kind of like
photo editing sometimes
when you are just playing around
with different aesthetic
features but in this case, right?
Like I'm making choices
based on sort of like my
aesthetic preferences.
Some of those have to
do with the data itself.
I want to highlight certain
features about the data.
Like I mentioned about
the color, for example
but this is not the one
right way to do this.
And also it's not the one right
data to actually play with.
So there's a lot of stuff
you can visualize from this dataset.
If you have questions or you
don't know what's the right way
to visualize something,
there are a lot of people
you can chat with in
different forum online.
And then also you can
always reach out to me
if you have questions about stuff too,
there is no one right data
viz is for something, right?
There are some best practices
which we've talked about,
but a lot of this is just getting a feel
for how to make your own visualization.
So I don't feel like you
need to stick with exactly
what I'm doing and feel
free to experiment.
'Cause that's where it gets fun.
And the last thing we're going to do
in this leaflet function.
So again, every single one
of these is a pipe function.
So add provider tiles add polygons
is very kind of deep outlier format.
So we've added our polygons
and then we're gonna add our legend
and we're going to put this
position on the bottom, right?
I'm giving it some opacity.
So it looks, it's hovering
a bit over the map.
And then again, we have
to match our color scheme.
So that pal function we defined before.
Same thing up here, values
again, being case rate
and giving the legend
at title as well too.
So let's run this whole thing.
And so you'll see sort
of how the code lines up
with what we see.
I can run this map interactive
is the one we just made.
One thing you'll probably remember
is that our big data frame the all MODZCTA
had a lot of weeks in it.
We went to long, a lot of work
to get all those weeks out there.
This doesn't actually specify a week,
if you notice in the code
I'm not actually pointing
it to a specific week.
So what this is doing is just
taking one snapshot of it
and kind of stacking all the
polygons on top of each other.
That's sort of why it
took a minute to load
which is not what we
want in the final product
but just for visualization
of kind of the aesthetics
of the whole piece,
this is what our kind of final product
will roughly look like restaurant.
Imagine as a rough draft,
this is an interactive map.
So I can, you know sort of play around
and drag zoom in, zoom out, zoom in.
There's a lot of data on this actually,
you can see the structure
of the different boroughs
and this is colored in based on case rate.
As you can see, right?
Every time you hover over something,
you get a little bit of
feedback here from the coloring
and you also get that pop up information
that we work to construct.
So you have the zip code
and then you also have the number of cases
per a hundred thousand people.
And this is nice
because you have that backdrop
with the information about,
you know, versus from open
street map is just the actual,
you know, city itself is behind it
but you then also have
your polygon stacked on top
and the color we mapped
all possible cases.
So our highest possible case number
was in like 1400 something.
And so that's in this top range.
We set as a sort of auto
cut the full spectrum
into nine evenly created bins.
And so that's why we
have these 200 size bins
but of course, right?
Like you can play with this.
You can set it such that each
bin is a very defined number
and the bins are like, I don't know,
zero to 50 then 50 to a hundred.
If you do that, though, you have to,
you know remind the viewer
that the bins are not equally sized.
You might want to do that in this case
just because of how the bins or excuse me
how the cases are case
numbers are distributed.
But in this case, it's as simple
to just cut it automatically
into this number.
Especially with cases on the rise
addressing the y-axis with cases rising
is a kind of depressing thing to do,
but you have to always
check to make sure your data
is actually within the
scope of data color.
Okay? So now that we
have our interactive app
the kind of standalone leaflet.
You can save it using
save widget function.
So doing this.
This is the object name.
So this one's called map interactive
and then you give it a actual file name.
So was an actual HTML file.
You can then load this up wherever.
So this HTML file, you
can drag into any browser
loaded up there, and
it's an interactive map.
You can scroll around
it and view and share,
which is really cool.
So this is how you would
export a leaflet map.
Now we're gonna flip over to
building this into a shiny app.
So if you, again, if you
have no idea what shiny is,
and what I'm talking about,
definitely check out the other video
that I go into and explain
what shiny is and how it works.
And so very fundamentally a shiny app
is a way in which you can
use R to create a web app.
So if you want to make
a new shiny app in R
you can do this pretty easily, new file,
lots of options you can do here.
I'm going to say shiny web app.
And when you do that, you give it a name.
So in my case, I called it NYC COVID
and you have the option
of doing multiple formats.
So I am doing a single file.
That's just my preference.
But if you want, you can do multiple file
where you have a UI file and a server file
because for every shiny app
you have to code for
both halves of the app.
There's the UI.
This is a user interface,
and there's a server side
where you would include your functions
and computations at the,
you know, connect the
inputs and the outputs
that the user is experiencing.
I already did this, so I'm
not going to reinitialize it.
This is my app to R script.
So anytime you do this in R it gives you
some really nice commented
out information here,
to run it, you can literally
just hit the run app.
I'm not going to do that just yet.
'Cause we're going to walk
through how to make this.
RStudio has a bunch of
really great tutorials
on how to work with shiny.
I also included a couple
of resources specific
to shiny in the links on the page.
So definitely check those out too.
The reason why I made
a new script for this
and not over here is
just for kind of like,
code project organization.
You could in theory, do
this all in one script
but in my opinion, that
gets a little bit messy.
So just for clarity, I, for any shiny app
I usually make a directory.
And so this case is NYC COVID
where I have my app.R script.
So this is the actual app
for the shiny web app.
And then the other
thing you'll notice here
is I put, actually this
is the wrong RDS file.
I put the data frame that
we're going to work with here.
And the reason I did that.
So let me show you over here, all MODZCTA
our data frame is all MODZCTA.
And I want to save this as an RDS file
that can then be initialized
for the app itself.
And so this is how I'm connecting.
The two R scripts in a way you
can do this in multiple ways.
You can actually like initialize a script
within another script
and do like a lot of cool
connected script stuff,
which is fun.
But in this case, it's just one data frame
that I want to reference
that we already worked to build
in this case I'm just
going to change the path
to be actually inside this folder.
So I'm going to redo this
and then you'll see a popup over here
cause she to get rid of this
one, just so you don't need it.
And that's the RDS we're
going to use for the app.
And so this is really good
to keep your app scripts in one place,
just so you keep everything together.
It's just a good practice for
kind of project organization
when you're working with lots of code.
So now that we're here in our app,
just you remember, right?
We're trying to build something like this,
this type of map.
But make it such that the
user kind of determines
what you're looking at.
Do I have my libraries
I'm initializing as before
I'm going to use shiny
for for the app itself
leaflet for the interactive map,
tidyverse for data wrangling, HTML widgets
again, for the labels
on the interactive map,
setting the working directory,
I'm going to read in that
file from my app script.
So that should already be in
the directory where you are,
which is what I've set.
Now we have the data frame
ready to go for the app.
We have to define a UI
first for the application.
And so again, this is what
the users experiencing
when they are interfacing with the app.
So in terms of inexperience
for an app, right?
You could either be inputting information.
So making a selection for example,
or you can be experiencing something.
So like viewing a graph,
playing with the interactive graph.
So in that case,
that's sort of what
we're going to build here
in a sort of simple fashion.
And so for the UI, it's
always a fluid page function.
The structure of this that I've decided
to kind of build here is I
want to use a sidebar layout.
So that just means
there's going to be a panel on the left
and then a pedal on the right,
as well as just an easy
title panel at top too.
When you're making a shiny app.
The first thing you should
do always is to think about,
for the UI at least they think
about how things are going,
where things are going
to exist with the app.
I'm going to run this quickly
just so you have a sense
of what the interface
is going to look like.
So let's hit run app,
it's a little play button.
Okay. So this is the the
kind of final end product
we're building this, when you run the app,
it creates a sort of
like local like window
within tied to RStudio.
You can actually also click
this openness in a browser
whatever you have for now, we'll
just supposed to stay here.
So this is the layout I've chosen
just because of the window itself,
when it pops out was kind
of looking like the sidebar
was actually on top
but that's just because
of the window dimensions.
So in this case, right?
I've additionally used a sidebar layout.
So I have the sidebar panel here
where I'm putting specific features
and then my output is actually
going to be over here.
And that's where the leaflet
a map is going to live
and putting my title here
which I now realizing I need to fix,
because remember this is not
actually ZCTA, it's MODZCTA.
So I'm going to add that in a second.
I have a URL here, and
then I also have some texts
about the data itself.
I'm also going to tinker with in a second
but the main thing here, right?
The issue we had with R
sort of single leaflet map
was that it sort of took all that data
all those polygon shape
files for the week ending
and just stack them all for
all the weeks, all the time
which isn't really helpful
when talking about a trend
you just are looking at like one state.
So in this case
relating the user choose
the week to look at.
So in initializes, such that it starts
when the data collection
for this metric started.
So that's the week ending in
August 8th of last year now
and then looking at the case rate here
I'm actually also building,
since we have the data for
that in the frame for test rate
and percent positive.
Again, this is the beginning
of the data collection.
So this is in August.
That's why the colors kind
of look a little bit lower.
I'm doing three different
color schemes here.
Part of the reason I'm doing that,
is because I want you know each metric
to have its own kind of unique identity.
They're not the same
thing highlighting, right?
These are different metrics.
If I use the same color scheme,
someone could come in and think
these things were all tied to each other.
Of course they're connected
but we don't want people
to misinterpret what
they mean for case rate.
I actually ended up changing this
to this yellow green palette,
just because I wanted to
provide some distinction
from percent positive,
which I think is arguably
the most concerning metric
and a sense of urgency.
So I added that red color
to be associated with that.
You have to always think about,
how colors are perceived by people.
It's not just an accessibility thing
of like someone being color blind,
which is very important to consider
but it's also the associations people
have with color, right?
So green here, people tend to
associate it's a calmer color.
It's a more like active
color, which is why I used it
for the cases in this case,
you can really put whatever
color you want here.
I wanted something that was just distinct
for kind of like the sort of
scale with lighter being less
and darker being more,
I think doing the reverse will
be confusing in my opinion.
But again, this is,
there's no science to this.
It's very much an art in terms
of designing the graphics
and that I chose a blue
palette for a test rate.
And so now that you have
a sense of sort of like,
let's go back into the nitty gritty,
always remember to like close
the app or stop running it.
Otherwise RStudio isn't really functional.
So make sure you do that.
So if you remember,
I said I was going to fix the title panel.
So now I'm going to make
it this modified ZCTA.
So I'm not hiding at all.
When I'm showing this, these
are, you know, they do line up
with zip codes, they encapsulate zip codes
and represent them,
but they're not always
individual actual zip codes
since we talked to them
about those nuances.
And so within the sidebar panel
that like clump of text I had,
the first thing I had actually was a URL.
And the way you do this,
this is if you have an
experience with HTML,
this is taking directly from
that to work with within R,
and so what shiny lets you do
is you add in this tags dollar sign A,
which lets you create a URL.
And so first you write in the URL link
and then I want the text showing
to just say data repository.
This, you know, the data
that we pulled from.
So anyone should be able to replicate this
and also putting target equals blank
which is a way to initialize the link.
So if you click it in a new browser
so instead of just
refreshing losing your app
it'll just create a new browser
just a nice thing to add
for the user's experience.
And then each file,
this is another kind
of way to add in texts
for HTML and CSS.
And here I'm just literally
writing some notes
about the data.
So someone would just stumbled upon my app
looking at it for the first time.
They have a sense of what,
where the data's coming from.
So the very important thing
I wanted to highlight here
is that data metrics
are aggregated by week.
So categorizing by week ending in a date.
So they have some reference point
before they go down to the scrolling,
what is percent positive bin
because that's not explicitly
obvious from the data.
So I'm saying indicates
percentage of people
that test for COVID-19
with macro tests who
tested positive, right?
So the denominator
is people who actually had
a molecular test for COVID
and the numerator is who
tested positive in that case,
if you get the percent,
all data source from the New
York City Department of Health,
the other thing I'm going
to do here is add in a note
about MODZCTA.
So If you wanted to as well here,
you can add in another tag
link with the direct URL
to that one, the one branch, excuse me,
the one folder inside that repo
that shows you that conversion table.
You can do that if you want.
Or you can just kind of say like,
it's also in that data repo.
So I'm just adding this
as again, more context.
I think the more you
can explain the better
you don't want to overwhelm people,
but I think being as upfront
about what you're showing,
is always important.
Okay. And then the most
important part for the user
is the actual choice.
So we're adding in a
select input tag for this.
I'm just doing a select
input where I'm making a list
of choices based on every
possible week ending
in the data frame.
And so that is,
I'm doing that by unique
and then week ending.
So any unique week ending
date is propagated into a list
and then the text prompt
in that select input
is just gonna be selected
date week ending.
And so that's what the user sees,
and then organizing
the actual output side.
What we're gonna do,
you know, write the code for it below here
is going to be a main panel.
So this is again within
the sidebar layout.
Now I'm working on the
main panel part of that.
And then as you remember
I had three tabs there that
you could select across.
So this is going to be
our three leaflet maps.
And so the way you do this is
you nest in a tab set panel.
And so I have three tabs
here one being case rate,
test rate, and the percent positive
the most important thing in any shiny app
are the other names you actually
give the different inputs
and outputs.
So always remember for
shiny app for the server
is we're stitching together
the inputs and the outputs
that's why the server always
has this format of function,
input, output.
And so we need to remember
what we named different things in the UI.
So for the select input it's date
and we're going to talk about
where that shows up in output.
And then for the actual plots,
the names we're giving
them our cases, tests,
percent positives.
So this can be literally anything
I'm giving it something informative.
So I don't forget what
the inputs are being named
as well as the outputs.
But yeah, again, if you ever forget
this is where you have to
reference for the names
and those names have to match.
If you want there to be
any kind of interaction
between inputs and outputs in your app,
jumping to the server now,
again, we have the format
of function input output
and I'm gonna open these up in a second
but just so you have a sense
of the general structure of this, right?
We're defining the sort of
function and then to run the app
you just run your UI and server.
The first thing I'm doing here is actually
I'm creating a reactive
part of the power of this
is by using this reactive function
making this reactive function I should say
is that this is dependent on
the choice the user is making.
So this calculation, this
function only happens when
the user is actually making a selection.
And so what I'm doing within this reactive
is I'm writing this
function, just sit here.
I am taking my entire data
frame and I'm selecting,
I'm filtering that data frame down
to a specific weekending which
was, you know, the goal here.
And how am I defining that?
I am saying input, which
tells the server, okay
we're looking for something
that we named in the input
and that name is date, right?
And so that matches date.
If I had more inputs, you know,
that's how you would class
and call different different inputs.
In this case, I just have one.
So this is how I'm
selecting the specific date.
I care about that date, right?
The way we named this is,
it's a list of week endings.
And so one of these week
endings is being selected
and I'm telling this reactive function
to filter my big data frame
just for that week ending.
So I have that set of
polygons to play with, right?
It's going to close this really quickly.
Then we want to build our three tabs.
So each tab is just gonna
have a leaflet map on it.
Not really add anything
else you, you could,
of course if you want it to,
but for this I'm just making
a leaflet map for each.
And this is going to look very familiar
to what we just looked at
for the the single leaflet
map we already made.
So for cases, I have a pal color function.
And so that is a museum
of color bin once again,
in this case I am choosing
a yellow, green palette.
Again, check out our ColorBrewer
for a full list of kind of
like embedded color palettes.
You can make your own if you wanted.
There's a whole bunch of things
you can do with color palettes
in R, in color in general.
The thing here is that I'm
actually setting the domain
for the color bin
to be the entire range
of case rates, right?
So no matter what week you jump to,
it's one fixed color scale.
That's really important
actually because you don't,
the whole point of this app
is for people to compare
the severity of case rate over time.
So if you don't have a constant,
you know, color scale
across all of your weeks
that becomes a kind of very difficult
at least visual process to you.
The numbers might tell you a story,
but you want the color
and the color scale to
match that experience.
And just like everything
else we are using,
we're making those pop-up labels
like just as we did before.
So MODZCTA and case rate
are going to show up there
so we know where we are.
But if you notice here
I'm not taking the entire
data frame anymore.
What I'm doing is I'm taking week_ZCTA
so what was week_ZCTA again?
This was this reactive function I defined.
So no longer is this a data frame.
And this is why I have this
extra set of brackets here
because I'm taking a function actually
and calling something from it.
And the reason why it's a function
is because this is happening only
when someone is picking a week ending.
So it looks a little
weird like it's not normal
kind of data frame, column selection
but this is, this will work.
This is the kind of
inside shiny nitty gritty.
Now we get into the actual leaflet map.
This is almost identical
to what we had before.
Big difference I'm not starting
from my entire big all MODZCTA data frame.
I am just starting from week_ZCTA.
So this is again a function.
So that's why we have
these closed brackets here
starting from that, because
it has the data we needed
it has the geography data,
it has all that stuff
but now we're running it off of that.
It's the filtered list
of polygons as it were,
leaflet again, we're
adding our provider tiles.
I'm actually doing one more thing here
which is sort of optional,
but it makes the work kind of
a little bit faster for shiny.
So think of, these are all processes
happening every time you
make a choice in the app.
So what this is, is I'm actually setting
the scope of the map from the outset
before I even add any polygons
what this is, is actually
coordinates for New York City.
This takes a little bit of trial and error
to get the right initial kind of viewpoint
but we're taking coordinates
launched your latitude
of New York City.
You can Google this and look this up
for wherever you're mapping
and also setting a zoom
so that I'm focused sort of in this space.
So you have a view of all the boroughs
without like too much extra from,
you know, surrounding
states and things like that.
So that's just like a fun leaflet trick.
And then we're adding in our polygons.
And this is again, identical
as above as we've done before.
Again, the only difference in this case
is I'm saying week_ZCTA
instead of the full data frame,
it's still a function.
So we're using the closed
brackets and then adding a legend.
The legend isn't tied to that reactive.
It's tied to the broader data frame.
That's why I just have,
you know dash case rate here.
This is how you kind of
modify your leaflet code
to make it into something
that is interactive
in a shiny app note also
to generate a leaflet map
within shiny you have to run
this render leaflet function.
And that is how you kind
of create this output
exact same thing for tests
and percent positive.
I'll just show you,
I chose a purple blue scale in this case,
and then present positive.
I use the orange red color scheme there
for the pallet spectrum.
Also gonna harp again on
this idea of how we identify
the specific output tabs we're doing.
So where, you know, we have
to actually tell an interface
and some of the UI.
So again, much like we had
for the input date object
we want to call specific output names.
So just as I said before, we
have three leaflet outputs
we coded for, they have
the names, cases, tests,
and PCTPOS.
So that's what they're called here.
And this is how the UI and server
then communicate with each other.
So let's run a one more time.
So now we have our updated text here
where I have a little bit more rundown,
you can click data repo
and they'll take you
straight to the GitHub.
And we have our three tabs,
which look really nice.
So let's jump, let's jump
around a bit actually,
let's go to end of November
and just said that you
see the maps updated
with the new data.
All ready we're seeing
some darker colors on here
suggesting a higher numbers for cases
as well as test rate and percent positive.
And then our most recent
data point is not great.
Yeah, at this time cases
have been really taking off
across the city and the state.
And so this is reflected
actually by a couple of metrics.
So for the case data, you can see that,
the actual number of cases
in this specific week
has increased quite a bit and
the number of tests as well,
but it's not, you know, they're telling
like somewhat different
stories as well, too, right?
The interpretation changes somewhat.
And so this is a good place, right?
You have a first pass at a shiny app
and you look at her like,
okay, so does this make sense?
Like this is jive with
what I was experiencing
with the data when I was
kind of inspecting it
on the front end.
And is this the sort of
story I want to tell.
And at this point, this is kind of like,
you know, imagine like
you're writing an essay
and this is like the
first draft of an essay
you go and then ask like all right,
what are the interpretations from this?
Like what can be improved
to better drive home
a specific story?
Can we add any more context?
Annotations things like that, right?
But bare bones, this is pretty good.
First effort I think
there are there places
where you can improve on this.
And so you definitely should
try, for example, right?
People might be like,
oh, like why are the cases
and tests and present positive
kind of like out of sync with one another
in terms of maybe like people
are just looking at like,
oh this is dark, but this one isn't dark.
So like, why is that?
And that's a complicated thing to answer.
So that might actually require
another like text blurb
or an explanation to see
what's been happening.
If you notice discrepancies in the data
this is also a cool
opportunity to like reach out
beyond the GitHub or elsewhere
to the New York City Department
of Health and ask them like,
hey, like did you guys experience
some data recording issues
reporting issues as well too?
As I said before, the holidays
hit a lot of people hard
in the sense of data
being lagging for COVID
across all fronts pretty much.
So this is a very cool way
for people to experience
kind of COVID data, right?
You have this level of interactivity.
So people living in New York city, right.
They might be like, well,
I live in this zip code.
Like, let's see how that
looks for cases for tests,
for percent positive,
maybe how to interpret
different levels of cases
as well too.
So I'm just going to jump around a bit.
Yeah, this is right
before holidays, right?
So this might be a bit of
precarious time reporting.
And so if you're wondering why maybe
the scale looks the way it does
when most of the data is
in this kind of lower zone,
we had a couple of pretty intense weeks
where certain zip codes and regions
had very high number of
cases per a hundred thousand
and easy way to improve this, right?
Would be to change the bin structure.
For example, if you
wanted to to bin that way
to kind of cover the the variability
in these lower levels
of cases, for example.
This is a good starting off point
for people getting into data
vision and visualizations.
And I talked about a bunch of
different really cool tools
that R offers, R and RStudio offers.
So shiny leaflet, these are cool ways
to create interactive data
without going through kind
of more front end tools
like HTML and CSS and yeah,
let's you really have fun
with the data and there's
really a lot of possibilities
you can do with this.
You can make all kinds of shiny apps.
You don't even have to make a shiny app.
You can just play with a
single leaflet interactive map
hope this was helpful
and hope that you guys end up making
some even better visualizations than this,
showing all kinds of creative stuff.
You can take this stuff to, to
not just apply to COVID data,
of course you can take this
and apply it to whatever
your favorite data set is,
we are talking about COVID-19
the most important thing
is transparency and
understanding of the data.
And again, I will just say,
as I said in the other video
that when putting out
data viz for COVID-19
just always ask yourself first
like what new information
is the data viz showing that
hasn't already been shown?
Does this serve a public need?
Is this, will this be
wildly misinterpreted?
Have I done everything
possible to make sure
that enough context has been provided
for this visualization?
And the data is solid?
The responsibility is
unfortunately too high
for something like COVID viz
to be kind of careless with that, right?
So always keep that in mind.
But again, the data is
out there to play with
and practice on your own time always.
So whether or not you decide to publish
some of this data, I think, you know
there's a lot you can do with the data
even just to understand for yourself
like how these visualizations are made
and think about maybe the best ways
you would wanna visualize it for yourself.